welcome to this video playing thanks and
good game thanks good game yeah nice in
a nice name okay um we got them got the
French French tirage and well I'm not
not a very frequent wonderful player
some always a bit in bits tricky let's
see my first thing is I hope to get this
bloody porn back okay oh you lost me to
take them yeah damaging the pawn
structure cannot be that bad I guess I'm
sorry let's um let's play with those two
bishops on b2 and b3 always nice night
f-for the serm might be an idea should I
play Knight e5 maybe 95 yeah possibly 94
on f6 I don't really like this idea so
much I should have considered this a bit
ya know I probably just have to go back
right Nyjah form stop making much sense
and i still have h2 hanging yeah well I
don't know how much really he benefited
from all that but I should have thought
about this a bit more Queen deform 92
not good not good
I still wonders the song it looks a bit
it looks a bit unreliable the whole
thing okay maybe start with this but if
I ever maybe can go we five
hmm
I'm wondering night h4 maybe but this f5
here so there's not lots of pressure
there's lots of pressure only five hmm
and we're very close to to having some
some cute mates working like this is 96
made like that take it yeah rock d3m
fattening 96 made but there is no way
this is really going to going to be
correct still still interesting and I
was also briefly thinking about Queenie
five but probably not just just go back
that's that's okay if I've is now under
big pressure how is it going to to
defend it if you make not really move
the night anyway what I was trying to
say is that also the Queen sometimes can
shift to h3 with night a g6 in the air
yeah mm-hmm this is wide open if I go
Queen D for now I'm threatening on g7
and threatening d6 where is he going 95
maybe
hmm
rook d8 and rook the eighth there's also
Bishop e3 this idea if I take twice a
tues hanging NT 60 saying hh2 also ok
hmm yar not much choice in them
especially considering the time check
need to get this going this this is play
against g7 gamble this is a threat now
I'm Bishop g7 and 95 yeah possibly
I should be 70 it's not easy to defend
this I didn't see takes it takes mm-hmm
I don't really want if i take Bishop
takes I really don't see a good
continuation after that mmm Queenie 6
may be keeping a 5 under attack I'm
still attacking a look maybe g3 but this
looks scary g3 is very scary move
yeah maybe you can play look at eight
simply g3 Bishop g3 I don't really know
where this is any good yeah but maybe I
need to do that I really if i consider
after together okay I don't get it ready
if I cannot take a five let's let's
let's take first think later I am really
yeah that the g7 porn is under much
pressure on the long diagonal here I
have no t 7 or anything right hmm night
h4n a checkmate with 96 Queen age three
maybe try this try with this threat it's
maybe a bit like play for a trap but
it's not a bad trap yep check
check
tweenage second made very nice motive
actually will not win resign the green
retreating when it was really playing
for a trap with a little time on the
clock there should be some defense
against it Brooke funny and the computer
rook g2 f8 just going down yeah I can't
think about night f5 here yeah because
rook takes root g7 should be very nice
for wide but he has all kinds of ideas
like III here with a big counter-attack
this is obviously an engine line ship
chandlery check and the computer tells
me this is just totally drawn yeah
probably some some sort of Perpetual or
anything yeah it is a perpetual after
this check check check blush it gets in
all the checks yeah well very tough too
immature to analyze we I want to just
briefly go back around him I felt that
there should be should be something but
23 is right if 4g three years strong OG
3 of course of course because of Queen
age 6 I see I seem of course yeah look
at this if I go g3 and he plays 96 there
is this a move yeah check checkmate this
isn't this nice very nice of course i
didn't i didn't see that at all and this
means he cannot move the night
sickly you can go here but then this
route t5 takes and then that's okay
that's that seem check check now and
again mate again the mate the two
bishops are just fantastic here wow
that's very cute where q g3 I didn't I
didn't consider queen d 4 sir is
obviously much worse in comparison okay
it still seems that the computer likes
white a lot but it's of course a
different matter Queenie 6 immediately
was probably stronger and here all night
g7 is winning okay um why actually ah of
course because yep he needs to take with
this route mmhmm yeah well this is Jack
very easy he needs to take with this
rook and then luke t 7 is really a is
really deadly as there is the threat of
Bishop g7 is if he goes here for example
there is this I'm sorry the samples oops
and oops check me and made yeah some
funny funny mates and two tricks there
yeah I tried for this check check for
this one and got rewarded checkmate with
this checkmate okay this was also slice
some nice tactics in there hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching